You've said a couple of times now that when the
opportunity presents itself you'll speak with
Emmanuel Macron, but have you reached out?
Have you offered to,
to have you tried to call him and speak to
him now, and is he just not taking your call?
Yes we have and the opportunity for that
call is not yet, but we'll be patient.
We understand the disappointment and that
is the way you manage difficult issues.
It's a difficult decision.
It's a very difficult decision, and of
course we had to weigh up what would be
the the obvious disappointment to France,
but at the end of the day as a government
we have to do what is right for Australia and
serve Australia's national security interests,
and I will always choose Australia's
national security interests first.
A couple of weeks ago, Australia, the
United States, and the United Kingdom
announced a new security pact called AUKUS,
which will result in the three countries
collaborating in the Indo-pacific region.
The announcement of AUKUS sets up a financial
and strategic loss for France, and it also
represents an increasing investment by a subset
of western democracies in a specific region,
and it looks like Europe isn't being included
China's military is growing and it currently
has the largest naval force on the planet.
In 2016, Australia, equipped with submarines
that were nearing their end of service
and also feeling the growing pressure from China,
secured a 90 billion submarine deal with the
French naval defense contractor Naval Group.
And this deal would give Australia
possession of 12 shortfin barracuda-based
attack-class diesel-electric submarines.
The diesel as opposed to nuclear-powered subs
would have been cheaper to run and maintain,
but they would have needed to resurface more,
be smaller, and would have had
a weaker propulsion system.
The French deal became precarious after a lack
of demand for local Australian industry wasn't
fulfilled, along with cost overruns, delays, and
an increasing demand for more powerful submarines.
Nuclear-powered subs can remain
submerged for longer amounts of time,
are larger, and are also more expensive,
but when it comes to submerged propulsion
(speed underwater) nuclear power
is simply the better option.
The value of the nuclear subs seems to have
outweighed the value of the diesel ones,
and Australia has announced that their deal with
France is over as they put in a
new order with the United States
for at least eight nuclear-powered hunter-killer
submarines as part of their new security pact.
Across the world are putting their
attention towards the Indo-Pacific.
A pretty large place it's home to sixty percent
of the world's population, produces sixty percent
of the global GDP, and it's also the second
largest destination for exports from the EU.
For member states like France, a country
with more than a million citizens in
the area as well as stationed troops,
their objectives have been made clear.
France wants to be a stabilizing force,
promote the values of freedom and the rule of law,
and help solve certain geopolitical challenges.
For the EU specifically, by pivoting off
of individual member states' own goals
as well as being primarily led by France,
the EU has announced that they will focus
on reinforcing cooperation, promote
a rules-based international order,
keep open markets, and ensure
stable trading environment.
However, unfortunately for them on the same
day that the EU was set to make their official
announcement for their Indo-pacific
strategy, AUKUS was also announced.
And that means that the three countries that were
already notorious for being excessively
loud when it's not socially acceptable
decided to announce their own private clubhouse
in the indo-pacific region – overshadowing the
EU's announcement, and forcing europe
to reconsider their overall strategy
Macron has already begun signaling for a larger
push in European sovereignty –saying things
like europeans must stop being naive, when we are
under pressure from powers which at times harden,
we need to react and show that we have the
power and capacity to defend ourselves.
This statement happened alongside a new defensepact announced with Greece where France will
supply the eastern european country with french
frigates supplied by, of course, Naval Group.
Recently, Charles Michel, the European CouncilPresident also declared that 2022 will be the
year of European Defense: we want less dependency;we want more influence because we have valuesto promote
Next year, France will also take
over the rotating presidency of the council.
Although this mainly grants France
some form of agenda setting, it's
already clear that the french will
set the focus of their presidency
on power and defense with the european defense
summit also being led by Macron in 2022
If there is any time to look at how a european
army might develop, that time is now.
Back in 2020,EU defense ministers began working on a strategic
compass for security and defense.
The adoptionwill happen in the first half of 2022, alongside
France's presidency, and in that document we should
be able to see europe's vision, not necessarily of
the entire population, but definitely of europe'spolitical establishment
For what kind of security
and defense actor Europe will be.
Common defensepolicies fall under member states, which means that
they're essentially gridlocked – a single veto can
block its creation. Although the adoption of
the european army is highly improbable now,
there are steps that set a groundwork
where it becomes increasingly more likely.
For example, like in many other policy domains,Europe has fragmented military industries that can
cause coordination problems. Take for example Card,
CARD has recommened a joint development of different military defensetechnologies because a lack of coherence can
have a negative impact on the ability of memberstates forces to operate together efficiently.
An example of this is the European main battle tank, which is a combination of military technology
between Krauss Maffei of germany and
Nexter Systems of France.
Although it's too early to say anything substantial about how this
will contribute to European defense concretely,
it's a clear example of how fragmentationof the military in europe can be changed.
Overall a construction of a european army is likely to mirror other examples of where Europehas integrated:
Small incremental steps that
make a larger coordinated European policy that
ends up replacing national fragmentation
seem like it was always to be expected.